so hello everybody I would like to
introduce you to Chris Yonghwa his that
is an independent scholar he he has
written a book on traditional festivals
that you can probably see just behind us
here he is on the international document
society board so he's an expert on
Jacques you dude
he he's also an expert on techni City
the media and he also happens to be a
member of my parish and a friend of mine
and so we've been talking for a while
about symbolism he also has a very deep
interest in orthodoxy and symbolism and
how all of this comes together and so
we're going to have a discussion which
going which is going to center around
techni City the author Jacques Ellul
with who's he's an expert on but it'll
probably spill over into all kinds of
interesting things and so I'm really
looking forward to talking with him
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so it's not maybe you can tell us a
little bit more about about yourself and
and maybe a little bit about the you
were just at a conference just now in
Toronto maybe can tell us a bit about
that yes it was the the 28th annual
conference of the media ecology I media
ecology Association it was in Toronto
which happens to be one of the seats of
in a sense of reflection on media as an
issue in any sense philosophically but
also practically there's a such a thing
as the Toronto School of Communication
including such luminaries as Marshall
McLuhan and not her not her private
biblical scholar even L'Engle the
pianist said that some interesting
thought and practice around the new uses
of media the list could go on but one
can point out here that for many of
these people I want particles of the
riches with father Walter J who worked
on the contrast between oral and and
with enough abetik cultures many of
these cultures many of these thinkers
have in common that they have a very
deep personal faith that in work that
informs all all their thinking and it's
certainly no coincidence because being
rooted in tradition is possibly the best
vantage point to to have enough distance
from our modern environment which most
of us take for granted to see what's
actually happening to see the patterns
from a certain distance and by for
instance historicizing it or being
rooted in their natural rather just
practice what you enter it to a an
experience or world that is but it's not
the same as the modernity around you
it's and of course at the mental
patterns to just that you have imbibed
intellectually this whole tradition to
happen categories to tools to point out
that is the
differences with the current dines and
and and the evolutions that happened
over time the transformations because
well one one of the an interesting way
of of characterizing this this media
ecological approach as it's been termed
is that in it media are not means as as
as not seen as means of transportation
of data but of transformation of human
beings of of ways of being because they
all involve certain different foci of
attention with different senses
different relations to time and space
that are entailed long refashion by
different that by new ways of
communication in communication is
nothing a neutral conveyance of one bit
of data from point A to point B that
everything is in the way of the common
way of being and of moving between these
two artificially separated points that
it's it's yeah it means being in media
yes and then like in there that in
expression me being in the middle of
things right to understand that that gap
which isn't a gap that's where the life
actually is yeah and I think I think
that it's so important to talk about
this now because I would say that for
several Genet for several decades we
were presented media as it's almost a
transparent yang we were people were
trying to convince us that media was
transparent there was only this means of
transparent communication but now as
political discourse starts to fragment
as conflict start to arise in society
where we're noticing more and more to
what extent selection even just the
selection of information that that
attention is being pointed to is already
such a frame that to imagine then even
the actual structures of the media
themselves their matter of distribution
the way they frame space or their
spraying of a French sonority all of
this tension yes the way that they frame
attention ends up
not necessarily manipulating but
participating in the way that
information is received and because of
the breakdown receive it more and more
because because we can see our enemy do
it yeah we we know we don't see that we
probably do it too but we can see our
enemy do it because we have that that
distance from from what's going on and
we have actually because we could frame
our discourse in communication to say we
have much more in common with the with
the with our current so-called adversary
or enemy that we did with the people we
claim say to return to you know the
we're part of the same world and that's
what's important to understand because
that's the constant track of course
there's been plenty of movements at a
bit critical of modernity okay okay
we'll just mobilize it against that see
but but counter revolution assumes
revolution it takes the same forms yes
it's it's all based on project
mobilization so you end up at you may
invoke some values from the past but in
practice that you're actually a modern
movement and one probably even more
efficient as a modern movement because
you have the reassuring references to
the past
mmm-hmm yeah I mean some of the fascist
groups did try to to let's say use some
traditional ideas or some imagery
traditional imagery but it was only a
way to give a fuel to their to their
modern project yeah or they might not
what we can even give them the benefit
of the doubt maybe they were they were
even sincere about them but they were
fooled by that by I think okay we just
have to take sides firmly against that
and mobilize our energies against but
mobilization is already modernity and
the more you're fully mobilized the more
modern you you are yeah yeah so maybe
let's let's go with allude because that
Jacques Ellul is a thinker that I do not
know much about but many people who
watch my videos many people who I'm in
contact with they keep telling me that I
need to spend some time with the Berlin
to understand him a little more so it's
I I knew that I had my expert here with
me and so this is my chance as well to
discover a little bit about him maybe
you can tell us a bit about his own
because he was a he converted to
Christianity
and then his own intellectual progress
you could say what what are the things
that were important to him well I'm
tempted I'm tempted to to approach this
as like a starting in terms of events
what is the eluded known for well it's
for he came he burst onto the scene I
treat the international scene and and
and the english-speaking scene in
particular in 1964 where the translation
of his already ten year old book on on
on technique as he called it that was
translated as the technical
technological society so he came to
global awareness in 1964 but that was
just 35 years ago after he'd been sort
of involved in that scene but there's
just some there's a I think significant
anecdotes about how that came about
because it's a Aldous Huxley who came
across the original French Edition for
1954 and he was so impressed by this
description of technique as it was and
you thought well that this for pets
matches what I what they described in
brave new world it is important to big
this out at this moment worrying
refashioned by technology in all ways so
he convicts by different channels that
the publisher not to took to publish
this translation in that quite an impact
on sixty sculptures and but the irony is
that actually when this Huxley's book
came out in 1930 brave new world it came
out at the same year in French
translation it was picked up by a girl
and his friend Dan Ashe of the nose
actually we said well wait a minute
that's that that confirms what I've been
taking on my own right
so
so there was that influence of Huxley on
on elude and then he Lou came out of
Huxley they were take the the the point
is they were taking that just the same
way but they hadn't it took them two
thirty or thirty more years to become
aware but but it was only one way
because I actually couldn't have
suspected that someone was worth
thinking based almost kids were thinking
the same way insurance southwestern
France and Bob though in 1930 and they
had already devised the kind of critical
and even revolutionary approach to
counter this phenomenon which they saw
in their daily life and when I say day
it has to be said that it was this
friend that exactly would came to know a
couple of years before called nashumba
knew who he acknowledged that he
wouldn't have you know have said
anything original in this India in terms
of social ideas without meeting him it
was just that mean see do you have to
understand rocket had a kind of twin
conversion around 1930 wanted well you
had a conversion experience to
Christianity which seemed understood in
terms of Kierkegaard and cobalt on the
one hand and on the other hand because
his father was ruined by the economic
crisis he had the kind of conversion to
Karl Marx so ok our mark and count that
both form two forms of dialectic so is
every in terms very much of dialectics
of usually exclusive opposites so that
that's what his framework at the time
that he came across - on the new sort of
took the place in his social thinking of
Karl Marx but he remained that max
expert all all his life but they
basically would have been some sort of
Christian Marxist if he hadn't come
across this almost a class clown at the
the the the school they were one day
came over to talk a little was kind of a
kind of a nerd really a bookish kind of
guy and invited him to to do to campaign
exhibition outside and then in the
countryside and then they had these
these a unending discussions and Jackie
did was sort of overwhelmed by it by
Barcia Bono's sort of effortless grasp
of culture but most importantly his way
of seeing the patterns in embodied daily
daily life and he had already come to
certain realizations about about the
nature of technological modern society
that few people would would come around
to you know Heidegger and in Frankfurt
School were still some few years off but
on his own just but there's no there's
two it's the experiences that are
foundational for this for Shabana was an
intuition of technique it is one that
realizing that the the Balto streets in
which it brought up from almost
overnight the cats and the children had
disappeared there were released back
cars yeah overnight the city had turned
from a human environment to a network of
pathways for the circulation of these
mechanical motorised engines and that
was true of the whole of society but no
one talked about it and it was the time
of the great Wars the throne after so
and of course that it was also a
motorized war and but what he understood
also because it's for he didn't he was
too young to go to war but he cites is
his big brother come back and it being
kind of
shellshock impotent get incapable of
talking about this experience and what
struck him is the way a society can be
mobilized in in its in the people's
minds as well as all the resources of
the territory it controls and control
see they did it there's something
similar and comparable about the impact
of something like the car and modern war
as a demonstration of what industrial
society really is the mobilization of of
every everything in human reality as
resource to be concentrated with with by
the means to deploy this apparatus for
whatever end the end doesn't matter the
point is the mobilization in itself and
he understood that well things like
world wars or totalitarianism they were
just out of the ordinary
expressions of something that it was
just the fabric of daily life as it had
mutated we call this that the great
molting of mankind one once a -
triumphed over nature it's no longer
something that pressures in so much but
for that man had to rely on total social
organization so now he has to defend man
has to defend against society as his new
environment is second nature so we
understood that the struggle the the
both personal freedom and nature are
imperiled by modern society for the same
reasons and therefore they have heard
our common cause see I'm shown that he
was the inventor of political ecology in
France and possibly world worldwide in
the 1930s see people thing is something
that started in America or Germany in
1960s but the movement that he started
locally with it can be seen clearly as a
kind of ecological revolutionary
movement I concede that that not in
terms of
I think this of that idea or that
ideology but the common structures of
the of the modern world the state the
media propaganda motors transportation
and it's two changes would affect our
people
II thought they made their paper so how
do you see this is this is taking a
little bit of a tangent but it's it's
interesting to me because what seems to
happen now in the let's say in the way
that things have set themselves up is
that the modern state and the modern
media apparatus all of this has now
taken over the ecological discussion and
is using it for its own means it seems
to be to be using it to also to let's
say to manipulate people into certain
directions it doesn't seem to have
anything revolutionary about it anymore
well exactly and and no one was better
placed on Menasha of the note to point
this out and in the first decade of the
of the actually existing French ecology
remove meant which was sort of started
seemingly out of after 1968 in 1980 it
came out with a book which he called
what the green light the self critique
of the ecological movement which actor
had translated for rooms very last years
the only shallow new book out there so
and that's good and introductions to be
stopped not by me but so if people want
to know more about travel no that's it
but but he could with this experience
going back 50 years it could see that
the that the the green movement I got
admired in the quest for media attention
as well and for presence in the
political system which of course is paid
by with media attention so so thus
critique of media is and as a kind of
categorical and poor imperative of our
presence in this world is central to his
critique of what the green movement and
had become and now it was in turn he
calls it the green light because because
it's
1970 was was decreed us as the year of
the environment by the
sell of Europe's Isola so it said oh no
one would touch this topic in Europe you
know until then but it was a red light I
knew it personally because Newton tons
of books about it and no publisher would
touch it see and all of a sudden 1970 it
comes from the Council of Europe
everyone that brought us these issues
there it was the green the green washing
pump was started rolling because it
started from bureaucratic centre from it
was it was already a kind of discourse
that that sort of papered over the same
kind of society and the people who were
trying to to to challenge this kind of
society they sort of did by clicking on
the same means Jewish this this society
propagated itself well they were sort of
co-opted by it since so that's why you
have a kind of green version of the same
kind of technology called society it's
interesting because what I've seen
because I I look at my kids you know we
we do homeschool but they use sometimes
books from the school system and
everything and and I can see that it
seems to be it seems to be replacing a
kind of the kind of guilt system that
was in the Catholic Church says yeah
1952 sixties where you had to really
feel guilty about being alive basically
being a human you with being a sinner
and and you have to live in this guilt
and now we've replaced that kind of
original sin guilt with this guilt of
living in consumer culture where you
have to consume and you you have to buy
things wrapped in plastic you you can't
avoid it but then you have this guilt to
answer a phone you have to recycle that
all these gestures these kind of social
things you you have to do in order to
atone for your your sins of just
existing in the world and you can see in
the books like my son has a math book
and in his math book all the problems
are all if you cut so many trees and
this area you know how long will it take
for the trees if they grow in such years
how long will it take them to grow back
so it's like all the mathematical
problems have become ecological problems
and it really struck me because I know
that in Quebec in the in the 40s and 50s
the map problems were all Catholic there
I am calculating how many chalices are
or using everything until I thought wow
it's a great way to indoctrinate
children this too how many Chinese you
can use can you convert and so it's a it
seems like it has become that this you
know even though I can understand the
need for for ecology I find myself
resisting not at the idea that you have
to take care of the world around us but
I find myself resisting because I see it
now as part of this apparatus this kind
of strange
techno powerful apparatus of control
well yeah and one of the the points that
shovel no mater early on is that
probably the the natural ecology
environmental measures would it would
not come about as the effect of some
grassroots environmentalism by marginal
groups it's when the very people who had
managed the the expectation and rune of
the earth when they couldn't do that
anymore they would manage trying to
rescue something of it but it would be
the same people the same system right
but but that even called it well the for
him it raised a bit the specter of eco
fascism because as it was one
illustration of the way
the chaos that is thread by this
constant encroachment of organization
needs to be managed by still more
organization which in turn generates
more chaos so so this so this builds up
that the drive towards social
totalization which source he saw a
danger of the industrial system
reverting well we reversing to to to the
kind of management of growth through to
a management and of endless consumption
to a management of scarcity where
everything would be precisely accounted
for out that but at the cost of personal
freedom and the part with the big
difference between him and say
deep ecologist who want to make you
guilty for being a human and in really
around the earth is that for him even
even the sense of nature of something to
be appreciated and preserve this can
only occur to a human yeah so so he was
just as concerned and as preservation of
freedom as far a for nature which was
before him in practice indistinguishable
for him freedom was a very physical
thing it was you know that is in his
childhood he used to vote that almost
down the street and be in the forest and
and we as years went by the suburbs
would eat up more and more and and
nature as a complete experience was
inaccessible and you are in a complete
you know a box store or an environment
that you can't get anywhere except by
car for him that freedom and nature are
none are one in that experience of
deprival that that that that industrial
society creates Italy it cartels both
concrete freedom has the ability to move
around in in a differentiated space in
the elements of air and water and earth
and also free of having to follow
standard procedures for everyday life I
mean our so-called instruments and
devices are not neutral you know for
that for in order for them to work well
we have to to adjust our behavior to
them we have to speak their language or
even when they pretend it pretends to
imitate ours but that's so that we can
integrate more their way of thinking of
operating you see we have to become
interoperable with our machines we have
to become interoperable with each other
that's one of the things that the immune
is famous for underlining these
different laws of technique as the
search for the one best way in in every
possible procedure and at that area of
life and as a totalizing process because
you can't just have it in one area
and leave the other areas inefficient
does adjustment work in order for
something to work efficiently it has to
work efficiently with every everything
else has to be connected by the same
rules to everything so if you introduce
one improvement in one area
everything has to for sort of fall in
language that you have to and of course
since the improvement continues
everything has to constantly adapt to
these new changes and even more
efficiently and quickly see so this
there's ever ever increasing in its
conformity in stranded standardization
even as the the process that drives it
is is the quest for convenience personal
freedom of choice whatever is in it
hidden because of that because that
interdependent and because things end up
speeding up by the fact that the
everything after that to themselves and
the efficiency has to grow in every
aspect then we realize that we've become
slaves to our that we that we've
actually like you said that we were
cyborgs already yeah and we are
completely dependent on on these
machines and if we didn't see it let's
say or very few people saw it with the
automobile although now we can see it
from a certain distance we can see
exactly what you said that now the
entire layout of society has been made
for cars yes we have we have planned our
cities in terms of cars but with the
cell phone that has now I mean I think
almost everyone who has any form of self
consciousness is aware of that problem
of the problem of how we end up living
we end up adapting our life to to that
to this object
well our life means which means much
greatly are our sensorial or our
management and awareness of space and
time I mean people have been articles by
people who was whose job it is not just
their job but their pleasure in life was
to do to read books and comment upon and
there they have observed that their
attention span
as drastically diminished he can't you
can't read a couple of paragraphs
without fidgeting to check their because
they've been literally rewired I mean
it's our you know our synapses are sort
of our neural networks or sort of they
become in structured by the stimuli that
we become used to and addicted to yeah
so yeah we've already been changed by
our side works well that may come in a
way of course the the phones will soon
be inside our our scope but that was
well really our inside then yeah the we
where damn or out there may be wearing
us yeah yeah that's very fascinating and
I think that maybe I would I'd like to
hear you talk about something you
mentioned just before you were kind of
going through and you you mentioned the
the relationship between the system the
the increasing of the system let's say
and the increasing of chaos at the same
time and then the the reaction of the
system to those to that to that process
let's say that's something really
interests me I can i as you know you
followed some of my videos you I tend to
talk about house the modern world seems
to actually be a rising of extreme
system and extreme chaos at the same
time actually that those two things are
coming up together because one feeds the
other exactly that's exactly what
trouble no was it was saying you book on
that yeah so maybe tell us a little bit
about our table know how it's up gonna
framed that it's hard to resume any
small yeah I know I know God you take it
from because it's also and it's at the
level that we're so so embedded in that
kind of reality that we we don't see it
so where can you sort of bullet or
certain distance to say oh yeah so let
he would
but let's assume somewhat pre-modern
conditions and know their local customs
regular ways of doing things or a
certain area and attempt to vary from
locality to locality it's a trap so you
introduce you bring it okay it will
bring in a road or will Electrify what
happens well pretty soon the whole
activity rather economic our socials can
sucked up but in my interaction with
this road or with the TV that just came
in well you know and millennia or
hundreds of years of customs as
disappear overnight where the appearance
of a TV screen in other remember my
first experience of strolling toward a
French village deepen in the Burgundian
countryside in 1980 I was struck walking
at night that there would be no one out
there and you would see these creams
flicker in every area of your house and
probably that we did that been the
experience 13 years before that all
these people with I agree who had these
extreme very particularized local
experience ways of spending time
together maybe around around the fire
after supper etc all of a sudden yeah
that this one
one common awareness coming through the
TV screen this one common folklore which
which overcame and erased generations
and centuries of ways of interacting of
meeting meaning making sense of the of
the world it would mean for instance
well you know even the local languages
it's well known that they well France
wasn't a french-speaking country until
120 years ago yeah as most people would
speak their own language the same thing
in Italy yeah there's only there's two
things that made most Italians speak
Italian
well I guess mom there was the force
sort of unit standardization policies of
the fascist regime but even that was a
that would even that was an outgrowth
after the first world war which you know
took you know peasants from everywhere
and just put in place to fight but yeah
to them in the apps and only people
who've been grown up in Sicilies and
never been never have never been to the
next village all of us all of a sudden
they were shooting Austrians and and
high in the Alps and they were treated
and the Italians were the worst a
three-team their own their own their own
their own soldiers I mean it would be a
temptation to go over to the other side
because it wouldn't be asked it's it's
no wonder that fascism came out of that
sea but that's where they are that's
where everyone learned Italian and the
frontlines and in the barracks the same
thing for every modern nation-state
which means the elimination of all these
particular cultures everywhere and
that's was something that one of the big
issues that trouble knew had I guess he
had in mind some kind of an
international of local very local
homestead or local local area because
even son the nation-state as a stage to
a kind of global uniform consciousness
because the nation-states are not
they're modern creations you know the
premise to ponder the the centralization
and uniformization within whatever fell
within certain boundaries well the the
central the language and outlooks of the
central government would be imposed
through throughout the whole society
and so the effects would be linguistic
but they're also yeah you have to school
them of course yeah to take them out
yeah there's a famous book by historian
Eugen Weber describing this process
called from peasants to Frenchmen so
that's about when the Third Republic did
in the late 19th century by by basically
taking all these peasants out of the
Middle Ages and and putting them in rows
in the secular schools of the Republic
and disa standing their uniform
consciousness and punishing them if they
spoke their own natural language like
that in this era so in a sense
globalization continues this process but
in which softer means of but more like
to seduction yeah I guess TV had done
that on the national scale before but
there's a kind of softer totalitarianism
inherent just to the technical system
that that probably works better when
it's in many ways when it's not under a
hard totalitarian political regime the
way I guess
American pop culture is the kind of
universal language of that and wherever
there's there's a there's any kind of
electric media well that does impose
itself as the kind of universal norm and
so what digital thing about the American
pop culture is that especially the music
was that it was positing itself as a
reaction yeah yeah right it's a positive
itself as a kind of rebellious
declaration of individual love you know
giving in to your desire yeah not
participating in the system but then it
just got sucked into to the same process
right yeah and became like you said a
kind of uniform uniform uniform language
of rebellion that could be managed
because we all knew what it was like you
can recognize a punk from every country
yeah never get they all look the same
yeah it's all these alternative grab
both cultures became just well well
there was disturbed at their roles you
know in the early eighties in records so
that would be the rahman and then the
alternative bin but they were still
records being marketed and made exactly
the same way you just have the
mainstream consumer niche and then you
have the other diverse alternative
consumer needs but it's they still come
to Manisha's they all function they're
all the same so that that's one of the
ways in which the medium the format is
much more important that the content you
have different different contents of the
same structure of individual mass
consumption consumption with with which
is not being very refined you know by by
finding these ever finer niches of
aesthetic or ideological Association
which by being identified by the proper
algorithms then you can tailor make
things so that they will meet their
expectations and therefore
standardized I mean even though even
more they they're made to fit what they
receive and did they develop a taste for
it and forget whatever can trouble this
is this is this form of a sensibility
that becomes referential and and
fortified in its own assumptions and the
more ever more intolerant of anything
that disturbs it in the same way there's
less and less the distance between
[Music]
desire and gratification or actually we
expect being gratified actually
gratification comes first and then this
desire goes to beat it Wow yeah that's
intense but I've seen that myself in my
own experience you know now putting out
YouTube videos I start to perceive the
algorithm and the content that I'm doing
is strange it doesn't you know because
I'm talking about symbolism religious
symbolism but then also movies and
everything and so I can see that the
algorithm is struggling to to fit me to
please place then once in a while I make
a video and I know when I'm making the
video that I'm going right into
of the algorithm like I made the video
to call Alex Jones symbolism of
conspiracy theory symbolism Alex Jones
right and that I knew when I put that
out that video and I put it I did
another video called symbolism
propaganda yeah and and I knew when I
put out the video that I was moving I
was going right into kind of anti social
justice whatever part of the algorithm
and exactly what I expected happened
within a few weeks I had a hundred
thousand views and and but then I was
like then that's dangerous because it's
okay if I make more videos like that
then I can yeah keep the attention and
so you have to whip yourself to to not
just to not fall into not to be
consistent not to be something that
feeds the Machine and I've seen
youtubers do exactly that where for a
while I was interested in their content
then all the sudden they found this this
wheel yeah they can feed and then they
just put all their content ends up being
the same kind it's become formatted by
the algorithm
and they don't realize that you know
because it's it's really like you get a
palette you can change if you you get
likes you get even moderate let's pop
those eyes yes it's very it's very
friendly but what do you think about
because there seems to be right now on
the internet there seems to be a war of
information you know use you have the
big the big tech companies trying to
censor you have alternative tech
companies coming out and then not being
you know like gap for example which
doesn't even appear on Google and his
head was branded right away as a extreme
right-wing group but I mean it wasn't
more the people on gap weren't more
right wing than the people on Twitter it
was just a kind of like the guy that
wasn't one of the one of the mass
shooters recently I remembered the
articles that came out right away when
they came out they said a gap user so
and so when I'm in shot a school but
that person was also on Twitter and use
Twitter I gab equally yeah but then they
said the gap user because Gabe was
pariah in this and then attended
information controlled it seems to be
going on we see and patron who saw
censorship we're seeing it on YouTube
Cindy monetization and like little ways
to
to push the the attention of people in
some directions seems to becoming more
more transparent because I also because
of 2020 because the election is coming
and you can see that they're trying to
direct the people's information for for
so but but what interesting is that
you're actually seeing the war because
when television was there you didn't see
the war there wasn't a war right there
was three networks in the United States
and there and Catherine see and there
was that was it
like that was they were feeding you with
a spoon yeah this is reality and just
take it whereas now it feels like
there's a war for reality yeah you know
what which reality do you want and then
then you'll get the whole world you that
comes with it the whole package of that
that take on reality which doesn't need
to do anything out there particularly
because it's the whole well it's the
virtual reality experience of having
this complete experiential worldview
that's complete unto itself doesn't
matter if you're guys in power or not
it's the same mental unit okay so this
is what's interesting in what you're
saying is that to a certain extent with
you with what you're saying is that
let's say there's several parties that
are fighting this war information war
that in a certain manner does it doesn't
matter because the two sides have
accepted the same yeah reality yeah the
same frame yeah and so because of that
it does in a way doesn't matter who wins
because what matters is the medium
itself or the manner in which
information and technology it's a power
that that has which is the most
pernicious you could say yeah the way
whichever brand of reality you're into
well you'll be your B's your brain will
be sucked onto your screen or your your
hand off device and and you won't pay
attention to your immediate surroundings
you know and and that that's that's the
upshot you you will be more and more
well a kind of organ of resource of that
of that invisible Wireless organism out
there which is now the real subject of I
guess most human history and it comes
back to you know one of the McLuhan
famous aphorisms humans are just the sex
organs of the machines they still need
us is doctor dude as in what kind of a
kind of a third party to do to make a
little detour true you know but but of
course we're promised the singularity
well will they will suffer because
reproduce yeah they won't need us
anymore
yeah and but if the singularity question
is very interesting because what we're
seeing is this we can we can feel that
we were slaves to this process because
you have people warning you have all
these people afraid of this this dai and
what the I will be and we have a whole
mythological storytelling yeah
terminator of the matrix we have this
whole mythological storytelling which is
warning us of that problem but we know
that it's inevitable because there's so
much money and there's so much power
that that the the fight is is gonna
happen well well well it's already fine
right the fight is just a one mode of
entertainment within the same media
whether you relish the prospect or
dreaded you're still fascinated by it
and you still pay bucks to see
entertainment on that team request and
it's still going
seeing these dystopian movies doesn't
inspire people to get off the grid no
they want to see more of that of that
Jhansi to feed their obsessions with our
not different than cash from those or
porn Watchers you know which they
probably are in there there when they're
not watching that
because also it's the same logic getting
kicks of intensity you know having
I guess some of your
[Music]
some of your some of the the levers of
your psyche pulled in inefficient ways
you know
so it's entertainment as whatever it's
counted that's the same underlying the
same as the same logical so we're hooked
on the spectacle of our own demise you
know it's the most entertaining for way
of approaching it that's that is that I
mean it is fascinating because it
we had a slew it's a bit less now but we
had a whole slew of you know
end-of-the-world movies in the 2000 it
was non-stop every year there was two or
three comets you know everything
earthquakes doesn't matter you know like
and and we recently there was a whole
slew of day we made the Planet of the
Apes in which the Apes are the heroes
and the human beings are the the bad
people the bad guys and so we are
actually watching we are we're watching
our own demise
you know we're rooting for the other
like we're rooting for the enemy and
this strange fascination with the did
with the demise of humanity also the
constant suggestions you know that that
machines might be well you know it it
well Terminator 2 are still up
optimistic if human if you machines can
become more human maybe we can't do it
then you have also need all these robots
should strive to become human even
because the humans like say that's
saying in Alien four see this this this
ruthless military that that's daughters
in horrible experiments about if that
represents humanity then the little
Winona Ryder Android you reach the bed
the Bible then has more humanity so we
see we sort of do these these transfers
we hope that there will be among
whatever succeeds us whether it's animal
or machine there will be something
that's less mindlessly mechanical than
we are yeah that's really fascinating
definitely definitely so maybe we can we
can kind of can finish off about talking
a little bit more about one of the
things that has been interesting to me
has been
discovering the notion of techne city as
supplement something that I you know in
terms of garments of skin yeah and in
terms of this idea of adding layers to
to to something which is untouched or
something which is pure really matter
are you characterize it but this
constant adding of layers and the dual
effect that it has on us and obviously
were in an extreme version of this and
it's my understanding that that that
group like allude McLuhan they've also
thought about that problem so so maybe
we can talk about that a little bit and
CeCe well yes because they're just that
it struck me with your own theory of
governments of skin there's something
kind of like that DNA in a dude I'm not
sure that he focuses that much on the
commerce of skin stage which somewhat at
the media ecology conference rightly
pointed out well that was the first
technology yeah a clothing and well
ruins and houses are very innocence also
an extension of skin yeah so but that
alien in particular as a biblical angle
to this is of course is not just a
sociologist there's two two two two
streams to install tent and they were
sort of conceived in outline together
around the time of the of the ward at
the sociological description of the way
modern society is and then there's the
theological assessment sometimes at the
same topic one kind of kind of
non-judgmental relatively because he's
always kind of moralistic really and and
then this day they openly theological
side and of course being the Protestant
that he is is a very very thorough
biblical scholar so that he really it
analyzes the the issues in terms of well
the first two chapters of Genesis and he
wrote a whole book on called it the
the the beaming of the of the of the
city as a classic Treaty of well these
these extensions of man that are city
walls and and gathering together as a
kind of he sees it purely in terms of
Pape of of Babel as a conscious
rejection of God to be in the self
enclosed human world and to me that's
kind of kind of over-the-top I think you
have a more subtle than that Chopin who
does to any and he sort of the subtle
hint and in the nature and Christianity
chapter of a shovelnose book the green
light we're certainly there seems to be
a subtle allusion to it - well well well
sure we have to do to find some some
shelter etcetera but well we're expelled
in nature what you expect you know and
we sure it's it's like a nude sort of
you see sees these protections that that
that man finds in his actual conditions
as inherently a kind of disobedience to
God and that's that's it and then at a
later stage God in His mercy sort of
integrates that after the fact in his
plan of salvation sort of sort of a
dream for him the city is just a kind of
okay man decided to live in cities so
I'll make a heaven in Jerusalem so he's
used I think there's more I mean there's
others there's the person who hasn't yet
I mean there are more serious much more
deeper reasons for for for for that
urban tsubasa symbolism of the last
thing yeah that allows and I think it
has to do it also with the fact that
they money it doesn't have any notion of
the icon for Hindus just he at the idle
right would you represent something
visually that's all there is you you put
a screen between you and God and that's
it the idea of a mediation of a healthy
mediation with the outside and even with
God
true God be to concrete objects is sort
of an aftermath of his yes the kind of
old Calvinist reflex right so there were
that interesting that he would see at
least he would under
stand that you would have the wisdom to
understand that the city is is that
actually is that who'd understand that
there's a relationship between the
problem of the image itself or the idol
or any form of exterior manifestation
and the city you know and and and to see
also the temple its I mean I don't know
if you you probably wouldn't go that
part but to understand that the temple
is also that you know that the temple is
is is it is already a hint of how the
city enclosure is transformed into into
something else
but for that to trap its description
seriously we need to read some of his
writings on this topic if we want to get
into the theological aspects which are
very much they're always in the
background in a dude as in the clue in
actually so what is a perhaps that could
be a focus of some other dismal right
because yes right now I don't think
either of us is truly prepared to get it
go down maybe we shouldn't do a little
bit the more homework well I'll leave
you with travel news book which is
chapter on nature in Christianity and
get of death what I called above those
schools approach to D to these issues
all right well thank you so much this
has been a great discussion and I hope
that we can go more into allude on this
question particularly because it
interested me very much later but then
also talked about I think it would be
interesting for people to talk a bit
more about McLuhan as well because he
was such I remember even when I studied
in college and was studying in art and
in the kind of postmodern world McLuhan
was a staple where people would quote
him and it's only later that I
discovered that he was a traditionalist
catholic yeah and then most of his
analyses of what was happening was a
critique and was it a celebration of
which most people took it that exactly
yeah and i think that that's something
that would be very interesting to look
into well so also a new there's a notion
of symbolism because the ads of every
rigorous thinking about that around the
different status of the word and D and
the image well you can see how this
relates to the the iconoclastic strand
see the opposing a bit like magnet
ruined in the oral world of the
experience of the word and the visual
experience of course of the image which
the visual world being that of the the
the what he calls the video as opposed
to the oral world of the true real which
comes from thing because in Latin that's
because you can't focus on one thing at
the time sort of pin it down and you see
one aspect that the time which is non
contradictory whereas with what makes
the oral experience of things in of the
word of course more symbolic is that it
sort of implies that it's never whatever
you get is not the whole picture there's
different aspects that you could get in
time and you and write and you could you
could theoretically circle it it's not a
visual thing like that again like not
like the bullet time of the matrix what
you get it from other angles and added
up I mean no our oral experience is
fundamentally different from that
there's always seemingly contradictory
aspect that coexist or even with what is
given it is not given see there and
that's it becomes a revelation of
something not given that that can come
to an overall experience of the word or
even of any perception because these
it's not it's not all that not so much
an issue of using that organ as opposed
to that but what is the ratio in the use
of the sword which which which organ
structures that the whole economy of
your senses you can you can you can hear
things visually and you you you and you
can see things overlays yeah that's
that's that's McLuhan territory okay
well I look very much forward to to
going in that direction so guys thank
you for your attention
and if you're interesting is interested
Kasab is part of the cephalic world
facebook group and he he is known to get
involved in discussions so so it might
be a place where some of the discussion
about this video we can have and see and
see what kind of what kind of soil what
can grow out of this soil so thanks
again for your attention guys then I'll
see you soon if you enjoy the symbolic
world content there's a lot of things
you can do to help us out if you're not
subscribed please do go ahead and share
this to all your friends if you can get
involved in the discussion we have a
Facebook group in which people can talk
about these subjects I will put all
those links in the description and also
if you can please support us financially
by going to my website
www.ihaveaspergers.webs.com